okay hopefully my tool is working now
but anyway so we were saying when x is
equal to minus .001 so we're getting
closer and closer zero from the negative
side f of x is equal to minus 1000 right
you can just evaluate yourself right and
as you see as x approaches zero from the
negative direction we get
larger and larger or i guess you could
say smaller and smaller negative numbers
right you get you know if it's minus
.0001 you'd get minus 10 000 and then
minus 100 000 then minus a million you
can imagine the closer and closer you
get to zero similarly when you go from
the other direction when you say what is
uh when x is .01
then you get positive 100 right
when you when x is point
oh my thing is frozen again
and it's
0.001 you get positive
1000. so as you see as you approach zero
from the negative direction you get
larger and larger negative values or i
guess smaller and smaller negative
values and as you go from the positive
direction
you get a larger and larger values and
let me graph this just to give you a
sense of what this graph looks like this
is actually a good graph to know what it
looks like just generally
let me
so let's say i
that's the x-axis
this is the y-axis
change my color
so when x is a negative number
right
as x gets really really really negative
right as x is like negative infinity
this is approaching zero but it's still
going to be a slightly negative number
and then as we see from what we drew as
we approach x is equal to zero
we asymptote and we approach negative
infinity right
and similarly
from positive numbers if you go out to
the right really far it approaches zero
but it's still going to be positive
and as we get closer and closer to zero
it spikes up and it goes to positive
infinity and it never you never quite
get x is equal to 0. so in this
situation you actually have as x
approaches so let me let me give you a
different notation which you'll probably
see eventually and i might actually do a
separate presentation on this
the
limit
the limit
as x
approaches
0 from the positive direction that's
this notation here
of 1 over x
right so this is as x approaches 0 from
the positive direction from from the
right hand side well this is equal to
this is equal to infinity
infinity
and then the limit
as x
well this pen this pen the limit as x
approaches
0 from the negative side of 1 over x
this notation just says the limit as i
approach from the negative side so as i
approach x equals 0 from this direction
right from this direction what happens
well that is equal to
minus infinity
so since i'm approaching a different
value when i approach from one side or
the other this limit is actually
undefined i mean we could we could say
that from the positive side it's
positive infinity or from the negative
side it's negative infinity but they
have to equal the same thing for this
limit to be defined so this is equal to
undefined
so let's do another problem and i think
well this should be interesting now so
let's say
just keeping that last problem we had in
mind what's the limit
what's the limit
as x
approaches 0
of
over x squared
so in this situation
i'll draw the graph
and that's my x-axis
this is my y-axis so here no matter what
value we put into x we get a positive
value right because you're going to
square it if you put
if you put minus
so i mean you could actually let me do
it it'll be instructive i think so let's
say
once again obviously you can't just put
x equal to 0 you'll get 1 over 0 which
is undefined but let's say you know 1
over x squared what is 1 over x squared
evaluate 2. so when x is
0.1
0.1 squared is 0.01 so 1 over x is 100.
similarly if i do minus 0.1
minus 0.1 squared is positive 0.01 so
then 1 over that is still 100.
right so regardless for the put a
negative or positive number here
we get a a positive value and similarly
if i put
if we say x is 0.01
if you evaluate it you'll get 10 000.
and if we put minus .01
you'll get
positive 10 000 as well right because we
square it
so this graph if you were to draw it if
you have a graphing calculator you
should experiment
looks something like this
if you can see this dark blue so from
the negative side
it approaches infinity right you can see
that as we get to smaller and smaller
now as we get closer and closer to 0
from the negative side it approaches
infinity and as we go from the
positive side
these are actually symmetric although i
didn't draw that symmetric it also
approaches infinity so this is a case in
which
the limit
uh that's not too bright i don't know if
you can see it
the limit
as x approaches zero from the negative
side of one over x squared
is equal to infinity
and the limit
as x approaches zero from the positive
side of one over x squared
is also equal to infinity so when you go
from the left hand side at equals
infinity right it goes goes to infinity
as you approach the zero and as you go
from the right hand side it also goes to
infinity
and so the limit in general is equal to
infinity and this is why i i got excited
when um
when i first started learning limits
because for the first time infinity is a
legitimate answer to your problem which
i don't know and on some metaphysical
level got me kind of excited but anyway
um i will
do more problems in the next
presentation because you can never do
enough limit problems in a couple
presentations i'll actually give you the
formal kind of
rigorous mathematical definition of the
limits